"The only force strong enough to save our country--"
"Sometimes politics can seem very small--"
"Why does Al Gore say one thing when the truth--"
"...right to me and I'd gladly--"
"Kennedy, Kennedy, Kennedy for me!"
"Ike for president! Ike for President! You like Ike, I like Ike!"
This is one of the first televised political campaign ads.
It’s so simple: It’s a catchy song, there’s an easy-to-remember rhyme and a man with a name like
Dwight Eisenhower – known for being a military giant – is immediately made personable, relatable.
The “I Like Ike” ad really was the first campaign advertisement sent out in a mass-media form,
designed to directly sort of introduce Ike and his supporters to the broader electorate.
In 2018, political campaign ads have become major productions with complete narrative arcs – like films –
and can have a greater reach over social media than television.
So how did the all-American political campaign ad come to be, and how has it evolved into a multibillion-dollar
industry that relies on knowing everything about you? Well, it’s a story about increased access to the everyday American citizen – and it starts with Ike.
General Dwight D. Eisenhower wasn’t really a guy known for his charm.
He was a decorated war hero who had brought the United States to victory during World War II.
And when he decided to run for president in 1952, he wasn’t coming with much – or really any – experience with electoral politics.
So the challenge he presented to those who were pushing for an Eisenhower presidency was:
How do we take someone so well known and liked, who has no political experience and has terrible oratory skills, and get him elected?
Enter the television ad.
A big advertising executive approached Eisenhower with a plan for a TV ad campaign called “Eisenhower Answers America.”
The campaign was run by a bunch of Hollywood and advertising bigwigs who wanted to capitalize
on the extreme growth of television in the U.S. during the 1940s and ’50s.
Imagine: 40 million American households in 1952 had television sets.
That’s 40 million households that weren’t available in previous election cycles.
The advertising campaign was simple: several 20- or 30-second spots where Eisenhower was
answering questions about his vision and well, being sold as politically adept.
Daniel Kreiss, an associate professor at UNC Chapel Hill
says that it’s the Eisenhower TV ad campaign that really changed, in a way, where priorities are for campaigning.
Campaigns start to contest elections more through air wars than the ground wars, which is to say that instead
of going out knocking on doors, relying on strong political parties, campaigns and candidates
generally make their appeals to the electorate directly over the airwaves.
Politics becomes much more about sending generally undifferentiated messages to a mass electorate.
Now, Eisenhower won the presidential election in 1952 – and the personable ads had an impact on converting
Democratic voters and nonvoters to vote for him, the Republican candidate.
Eisenhower’s political TV ad campaign success set the tone for how elections would be fought, going forward.
And it continues through the election in 1960, with John F. Kennedy and Richard Nixon.
"I want to talk to you for a moment."
"Kennedy, Kennedy, Kennedy, Kennedy, Kennedy..."
By that election, 90% of American households had a television set. Compare that to just 9% ten years earlier.
And from there, the American political ad just continues to develop, with the infamous “Daisy ad” in 1964.
It was run by the Lyndon B. Johnson presidential campaign and attacked the Republican candidate Barry Goldwater.
"6...5...4...3...2...1"
The Daisy Ad was very unique in that it was a very direct fear appeal. The Daisy ad ushered in sort of a new
generation of much blunter messages.
Starting in the ’80s and ’90s, overall spending on election campaigning blew up, with a pretty big focus on TV advertising.
More than $300 million dollars were spent on political advertising in 1992 for both local and
national elections, dwarfing the previous record of $230 million just four years earlier.
"Government just isn't working for the hardworking families of America."
Now, we’re focusing a lot on presidential campaigns and political advertising, because it’s
those ads that have national reach and have impacted the growth of the political ad.
In 2000, George W. Bush and Al Gore went head to head for the presidency in probably one of the most
consequential elections in American history.
The Bush and Gore campaigns spent a combined $67.1 million dollars in TV ads,
hitting almost 200,000 spots, collectively, that year.
"Newspapers say Gore has a problem telling the truth."
And that trend of increasing funding for political advertising continued to grow, as more
and more people, especially those who were younger, started to live more and more online.
Starting in the mid-1990s, campaigns began shifting from running relatively undifferentiated, broadcast
television or cable television ads, that was seen by large swaths of the American public to increasingly targeted
internet ads that would at first be run on like newspaper websites or AOL dialup internet.
In the late ’90s, early 2000s and now to running ads on platforms like Facebook that allow
campaigns to buy particular audiences and show content in a hyper-targeted way.
And it was the candidacy of Barack Obama that changed everything for political advertising – and not necessarily for the better.
While previous presidential candidates, like Howard Dean in 2004, had used the internet for
campaign fundraising, it was the Obama campaign that used it to advertise, to mobilize voters and to push back against attacks from opponents.
"At this defining moment in our history, the question's not 'are you better off than you were four years ago?'
"We all know the answer to that. The real question is 'will our country be better off four years from now?'"
While then-candidate Barack Obama outspent his opponent John McCain by $173 million dollars in
2008 on political advertising, his campaign also relied on YouTube, which was a free space.
It’s hard to really figure out how much influence the Obama campaign’s focus on internet campaigning had on young voters.
But the 2008 election saw the highest number of young voters come out for Obama
than for any other president since 1972, when exit polling first started.
Oh, and get this – remember this viral YouTube video?
"It was whispered by slaves and abolitionists as they blazed the trails for freedom."
That ad is the one that’s believed to have put Barack Obama on the map –
and it wasn’t created for television or by the Obama campaign, but by will.i.am of the Black Eyed Peas.
But it totally became the Obama campaign’s anthem.
"Yes we can."
"It was whispered by slaves and abolitionists as they blazed the trails for freedom."
Obama’s 2012 campaign once again changed how the internet could and would be used for political advertising, anointing that election the first Big Data election.
The Obama campaign went all-out when it came to collecting data to better target voters
advertising – and Facebook was a huge part of that push.
The campaign collected and studied data on prospective voters, through public information,
and catered messages for specific demographics, specific areas, even people.
That tactic is known as “microtargeting” – and it was a big and controversial part of the 2016 presidential campaign.
Now, let’s take a breather for a moment to recap where we are: We’ve gone from this ad that reached 40 million
American households to political campaign advertising that’s collecting your data and
customizing messaging that targets you, wherever you are.
So broadly, the implication of that movement from mass to much more hyper-targeted publix
means that campaigns and other political actors are able to make increasingly narrow appeals
to very small slices of the electorate. And even more importantly, those people who are seeing an ad don't
necessarily know that they're seeing the same ads as other people. A candidate could say one thing
to one group of people, and another thing to another group of people, depending on what is strategically advantageous.
And we see what Kreiss is talking about in the 2016 election campaigns.
During that election cycle, then-candidate Donald Trump spent a fraction on political advertising
compared to his opponent, Hillary Clinton, who was slated by many to become the 45th president.
"Our movement is about replacing a failed and corrupt political establishment."
Trump was amazingly adept at earning free media coverage. By some academic estimates,
over $2 billion of free media on platforms like CNN, Fox News, during the course of the election.
The thing that the campaign then sought to do was to buy advertising around those themes and
target individuals on platforms, especially Facebook, in order to mobilize those voters further.
And you can mobilize voters even more because digital advertising isn’t as passive as TV ads.
Digital advertising is designed to mobilize.
And what I think the Trump campaign did very effectively was reach out to people
who were Trump supporters or likely to be sympathizing with them and then asking them
to take action in some particular way.
Now, while social media and the internet, overall, are powerful tools that can empower voters,
political advertising online is not regulated, meaning there’s potential for “anything goes.
And that “anything goes” caused a lot of outrage when it was revealed in 2017 that UK-based
Cambridge Analytica, a private consulting firm, had gained access to the private information of
almost 90 million Facebook users through an app.
That access violated Facebook’s privacy rules and the trust of millions of users in the platform – but not any federal laws.
One of the firm’s clients was the Trump campaign.
It used data collected on a huge part of the American electorate to micro-target its message.
*lets out a sigh of exhaustion*
So, again, we’ve gone from “I Like Ike” to … an invasion of privacy, *just* for political advertising.
So what’s next?
Where does political campaign advertising go in a world of Big Money and Big Surveillance?
Well, Naomi Burton and Nick Hayes – the people behind Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez’s viral
"The Courage to Change” ad – think the future is principled advertising for principled politicians.
Burton and Hayes are the founders of Means of Production, a socialist production company founded in the aftermath of the 2016 presidential
election, working on ads for a group of relative newcomers to the mainstream:
The Democratic Socialists of America! And they’re not afraid of being very open about having an agenda.
We really want to work with people that are pushing a politics, advancing an agenda, that benefits working-class people.
We draw a line and we won't work with people who take corporate money, because there's no interesting stories
We also only work with people who have a socialist politics, because without an ideological foundation, progressivism is co-opted.
And they found success with New York Democratic congressional nominee Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez.
“Women like me aren’t supposed to run for office. I wasn’t born to a wealthy or powerful family.”
I reached out to her on Twitter. I explained who we were, as Means of Production. I said, we take no corporate
money, we’re socialists and we would really love to make a campaign video for you. She immediately responded.
The next day we got on the phone and a month later, we were in New York.
Think the thing that made us want to work with her was she was unapologetically socialist and she understood
how to articulate those ideas that met people where they were at.
The final result was an ad that delivered a strong narrative that intertwined her own life with the
lives and experiences of so many of the people who would be her constituents.
It wasn’t televised, and went viral online.
“But after 20 years of the same representation, we have to ask: Who has New York been changing for?
Every day gets harder for working families like mine to get by. The rent gets higher.
Healthcare covers less. And our income stays the same.”
Ocasio-Cortez defeated her opponent, 15-year incumbent candidate Joseph Crowley, in the Democratic primary.
She is projected to be the next representative for New York’s 14th congressional district.
The viral ad didn’t necessarily introduce her to the constituents she had been campaigning to for
months already, but it did introduce her and her politics to people well outside New York’s 14th district.
So we’ve seen political advertising evolve a lot since “I Like Ike” first hit the airwaves in 1952.
And that evolution has been connected to the evolution of how people stay connected to each other and to the world around them.
But how much is political advertising really worth,
if surveillance has become an inseparable part of it?